بسم اللہ الرحمن الرحیم السلام علیکم ناظرین امید ہے آپ خیر خیریت سے ہوں گے
پیس ٹاکس پاکستان میں کامیاب نہیں ہو سکی
جو چودہ پناہ دن کا سیس فائدہ وہ فیلحال انٹیکٹ ہولڈ ہو رہا ہے
لیکن جس طرح ہم یہ بات کر رہے ہیں جس طرح پچھلے چوبیس گھنٹے میں یہ ساری کہانیاں ڈیویلپ ہوئی ہیں
امریکہ نے فیصلہ یہ کی ہے کہ وہ اب سٹیٹ اف ہرموسو خود بلوک کریں گے
یعنی کہ آپ پہلے ایران سے نگویشیٹ کریں
ایران آپ کی ہر چیز مانے لیکن پھر آپ جنگ مسلط کر دیں
جب آپ جنگ مسلط کریں تو ایران آپ سے دفعہ میں دنیا کو انوالف کرنے کے لیے
سٹیٹ اف ہرموز بلوک کریں
آپ کہیں انہوں نے بہت غلط کام کی ہے
اس سے بہت دنیا کو نقصان ہوتا ہے
تیل مہنگا ہو جاتا ہے
پھر اس کے بعد جنگ بندی ہو
آپ مذاکرات کریں مذاکرات فیل کریں
پر آپ سٹیٹ آف ہرموزو خود بلوک کر دے یہ ہے ٹرمپ لوجک یہ ہے امریکن پولیسی لوجک کیوں
ایران اور امریکہ دونوں کوشش کر رہے ہیں کہ میکسیمم ملکوں کو انوالف کیا جائے کیوں
انوالف اس لیے کیا جائے تاکہ ایک پارٹی پر پریشر ڈالا جائے کہ آپ ہماری ڈیمانڈز مان لیں
جو جی ڈی وینس کی مذاکرات یہاں پہ ہوئی پاکستان کی نگرانی کے اندر ایران کی پارلیمنٹری سپیکر کے ساتھ
اس کے اندر یہ چیز سامنے آئے کہ نوکلئر پروگرام کے اوپر ایران بج نہیں کر رہا تھا
لیکن در حقیقت لگتا یہ ہے کہ سٹریٹ آف ہرموز پہ ایران بج نہیں کر رہا تھا
اس کی بنیادی وجہ یہ ہے کہ جو ڈیویسٹیشن اور ڈیمیج اس جنگ سے کاؤز ہوئے
اس کا خمیازہ کون بھکتے گا
یہ ایک چالیس سال کی آپ سمجھیں میس انڈرسٹینڈنگ میس ٹرسٹ
اور امریکہ کی جہاریت کا ریزلٹ ہے
کہ ایران امریکہ کی کسی بات پر
ٹرسٹ نہیں کرتا
اس کی ایک سمپل وجہ دیکھ لیتے ہیں
اوبامہ نے ایک ڈیل بنائی ایران کے ساتھ
وہ ڈیل پاسوی کانگرس سے
ٹرمپ آتا ہے اور وہ اس ڈیل کو ختم کر دیتا ہے
اب جب نیشن سٹیٹس آپس سے موہدے کرتے ہیں
تو انڈرسٹینڈنگ یہ ہوتی ہے
کہ گورنمنٹ چیزے ساتھ وہ موہدے ختم نہیں ہوں گے
ان کی گیرنٹیز ہوں گی
اسپیشلی اگر آپ کا نیشن سٹیٹ
ڈیموکرائٹک ہو
یہ نہیں ہوا
چلے ایران نے پھر ٹرمپ کے ساتھ
نگوشیشن شروع کر دی
اس نگوشیشن کے اندر
امان کے فورن مینسٹر نے بتایا
کہ یار ہم تو
قریباً کنکلول کر چکے تھے
ہر چیز اور معاملات
بڑے اچھے لگ رہے تھے
لیکن پھر جنگ مسلط کر دی گئی
ریالیٹی یہ ہے
کہ ایران نوکلیر ویپن پوزیس کرے
یا نہ کرے ایران کے اندر
والیسٹک مزاز ہوں یا نہ ہوں
فنڈمنٹل پرابلم یہ ہے
کہ ایران کا جو ریولوشنری گارڈ ہے
اور جو اس کی مذہبی سوچ ہے
اس سے اختلاف ہے
اب آپ اوپن لی یہ تو نہیں کہہ سکتے
کہ جناب کیونکہ ایران ایک اسلامی ریاست ہے
لہٰذا ہم اس کو تباہ کر دیں گے
اس کی وجہ یہ ہے کہ آپ کے بہت سارے
ایلیز ہیں جو اسلامی ریاست ہیں
لیکن چلے انہوں نے تھوڑا وارٹر ڈاؤن کر دی اپنا ورجن اور وہ آپ کے لئے پیلٹیبل ہو گیا
تو لہٰذا آپ سے کچھ نہیں کہتے
تو یہ ہے کرنٹ سیچوئیشن
ایران کے آلڈی وارننگز دے دیئے
یو ایس شپ کو ایک ویڈیو ٹوٹر پہ بھی سرکولیٹ کر رہی ہے
جہاں پہ ایک ایران گارڈ کا شپ وارن کر رہا ہے
امریکہ شپ کو کہ آپ یہی پہ رک جائیں
اس سے آگے آپ مچ جائیں
ہم آپ پہ فائر کھول دیں
پاس اسی وجہ سے امریکہ نے اب مائن سویپرز نیول ویسلز وہاں
پہ جوک در جوک بھیجتی ہیں ساتھ ہی ٹرم ٹوئٹ کرتے ہیں کہ جناب
ہم نے ایران کی ہر چیز تباہ کر دی ہے نیوی تباہ ایرفرس تباہ
اینٹی ائرکرافت تباہ بڑی جیب سی بات ہے اگر آپ نے ہر چیز تباہ
کر دی ہے تو سٹیٹ اف ہرموس کیوں نہیں کھلوا رہے آپ ریالیٹی یہ
ہے کہ امریکہ جو پوسچرنگ کر رہا ہے اس کے پاس وہ بیک بون نہیں
یہ پوسچر کیا کہ ہم نے ہر چیز تباہ کر دیا ہے لیکن سٹریٹ آف ہرموز وہ
ٹس سے مس نہیں کر سکے اب امریکہ دنیا کو ایک بلیک میلنگ ٹیکٹک کے
اندر لارہا ہے دیکھیں جنگ امریکہ نے مسلط کی اس لیے اس کا کوئی
رائٹ نہیں ہے کیونکہ کسی کو بلیک میل کرے امریکہ اگر نیٹو سے گلا
کر رہے آپ نے کچھ نہیں کیا اور اب جپان سے بھی کر رہے آپ نے گلا
کچھ نہیں کیا کیوں کیونکہ جپان کا مجورٹی آئل آتا ہی سٹریٹ آف
ہرموز سے ساؤتھ کوریا سے گلہ کر رہے آپ نے کچھ نہیں کیا
آسٹریلیہ سے گلہ کر رہے آپ نے کچھ نہیں کیا
یوکے سے گلہ کر رہے آپ نے کچھ نہیں کیا
تو سوال یہ بنتا کہ حضور جنگ تو آپ نے نافذ کی تھی
آپ گئے تھے جنگ میں
اسی طرح کہ میں فیصلہ کروں کہ میں نے حملہ آور ہو جانا ہے
اس دفتر کے اوپر
جب میں اس دفتر پر حملہ آور ہو جاؤں اور دس پندہ دن
میں اس دفتر کو سیجھ کروں اور کوئی رزلٹ نہ آسکے
تو پھر میں کہوں گے
یار وہ میرا فلانا قزن تھا
چوتھے مولے
وہ میری مدد کرنے نہیں آیا
میرا پھوپی کا پتر وہاں کھڑا تھا
میرے جو بچپن کے دوستے وہ نہیں آئے
میں نے کسی اکاہی نہیں
میں تو اسرائیل کی ایمہ پر کہتا
کیوں کیونکہ ٹرامپ کو
ایک فنڈیمنٹل انڈرسٹینڈنگ یہ دیگی تھی
کہ جناب یہ جنگ تو بہت ایزی ہے
آپ نے دو تین لیٹر شہید کرنے
لوگ بغاوت کریں گے اور پھر لوگ کہیں گے ٹرامپ آوے ہی آوے
یہ وینیزویلا نہیں ہے
یہ اسلامی ریپبلک آف ایران ہے
ان لوگوں نے شاہ کو یہاں سے بغایا تھا
ریولوشن کیتی اٹھے ہوئے تھے
یہ پچھلے چالیس سال سے جس کنڈیشن میں رہ رہے ہیں
بیکاوز آف امریکن سینکشنز
بیکاوز آف امریکن جھاریت
بیکاوز آف امریکن وار کرائمز
یہ اس کو برداشت کر رہے ہیں
پاکستان کے بارے میں لوگ اب مخلف رائے دینا شروع ہو گئے
کہ جناب پاکستان نے سکسیسفل نہیں تھا پیس ٹاکس میں
یہ ہیومنشٹرین پہلی دفعہ کے سالے سو گالیاں پاڑی ہیں
بسید ایک بندہ ہے وہ سالسی کروارہ دو لوگوں کی
اس کا کام ہے ٹیبل ٹاکس کرنا ٹیبل پر لوگوں کو لانا
اب ٹیبل پر کیا بات ہوتی ہے کسیتہ نگوشیٹ ہوتی ہے
وہ تو ان پارٹیز کا کام ہے
پاکستان تو فسیلیٹیٹی کہتا ہے اور دونوں فریق ہیں
امریکہ اور ایران نے کمنڈ کیا پاکستان کی سالسی کی ability
کہ جناب انہوں نے gap bridge کرنی کوشک کر لیکن ایران کہتا ہے
امریکہ کی جہاریت اور امریکہ کہتا ہے ایران کی stubbornness نے یہ چیز روگ دی
اگر ہم historically دیکھیں اگر ہم صرف Trump administration کو دیکھیں
اور امریکہ overall کو بھی دیکھنا چاہے تو بات سہی میں
Trump administration کی سجا کھڑی نہیں ہوتی
اب سید عباس ارگاچی جو foreign minister ہیں ایران کے
وہ کہتے ہیں کہ جناب سنتالیس سال بعد پہلی دفعہ اتنی ہائی لیول انٹینسیف ٹاک ہے
یعنی یہ ون نمبر ون کے فائنلی فیش ٹو ویس سنتالیس سال بعد یہ ٹاک ہوتی ہے
ہم نے امریکہ کو گوڈ فیت میں انگیج کیا
ہم انچز دور تھے اسلامباد ایم او یو سے
یہ ان کی اپنی ٹویٹ ہے کہ انچز دور تھے اسلامباد ایم او یو سے
لیکن آگے سے ہمیں میکسیمالیزم
شفٹنگ گول پوسٹ اور بلوکیڈ کی دھمکیاں ملی
یعنی کہ جس موقع پہ بیٹھے مذاکرات ہوئی تھی
بیکڈرپ کے اندر نٹین یاہو اپنا کام کر رہا تھا
وہ کاروائیاں ڈال رہا تھا
وہ نہ صرف لبنان پہ حملے کر رہا تھا
بلکہ وہ حملے امریکہ کے اندر بھی کروارا تھا
جو ان کی کانگریس میں ہے
کہ وہاں سے موٹیویٹ کیا جائے
اس لیے ٹرم دے دے ٹویٹیں ہماری جا رہا تھا
اور بدنیتی کہاں ثابت ہوتی ہے
جب آپ جیلیٹ کشنر اور سٹیف وٹکوف کو دیکھتے ہیں
اس مذاکرات کمیٹی میں جو بیسیلی نیٹین یاو کے بچے ہیں
یعنی کہ اس وقت جب مذاکرات ہو رہے ہیں
تو بلو بائی بلو انیلسز نہ صرف ٹرمپ کو مل رہا ہے
بلکہ نیٹین یاو کو بھی مل رہا ہے
کیونکہ نیٹین یاو کا سروائیول اور اسرائیل کا جو
اس کا سروائیول ڈپینڈ کرتا ہے کہ یہ مذاکرہ سکسیسفول
نہ ہو
ایرانین پریزیڈنٹ مسود
پریزشکین نے کہا کہ امریکن گورنمنٹ
اگر توٹیلیٹریانیزم
اور ایران کے لوگ
کو ریجیکٹ نہ کر دے اور ایران کے لوگوں کے
رائٹس ایز ای نیشن کو رسپیکٹ نہیں کرے گی
تو اگریمنٹ ہم نہیں کر پائیں گے
اور اگر یہ وہ چیزیں کرتی ہے تو ہم اگریمنٹ
انشاءاللہ ریج کر دیں گے انہوں نے پھر
کہا کہ جو ہماری نگوشیٹنگ ٹیم وہاں گئی تھی
اسپیشلی میڈیر برادر دکٹر
مسٹر دکٹر کالیباف
اللہ ان کو سٹرنگ دے
کہہ رہی ہے اچھا کام کرے
کالیباف ساکھ کی خود ٹویٹ آگی
جہاں پر انہوں نے کہا کہ
انجوئے در کرنٹ پمپ فگرز
ویدھ سو کال بلوکیڈ
سونیل بی نسٹیلجک فور فور تر فائی بلالر گیس
یعنی کہ انہوں نے بھی یہ بتا دے کہ حضور
آپ نے بلوکیڈ کرنا ہے ہم نے بلوکیڈ کرنا ہے
ہماری بے معینی بات ہے ہم تیار ہیں
اس کی وجہ ہے کہ ایک چیز آپ کو
انڈرسٹینڈ کرنی ہے
جب آپ کو دیوار سے لگا دیا جاتا ہے
اور آپ کو کہا جاتا ہے کہ
ہماری بات مانو نہیں تو موت ہے
تو آپ کے پاس ایک بائنری ون یا زیرو چوئس آتی
اگر آپ چوز کر لو
کہ ہم آپی غلامی کر لیں گے
تو معاملات ڈی ایسکلیٹ کرتے ہیں
لیکن اگر آپ کو ہم نہیں کریں گے
پھر اگلے کیا کریں گے وہ مجبور ہو جائیں گے
they will be forced to take such action
اور آپ کو یو ای کے اندر یہ پروپگینڈا ہوتے ہوئے نظر آ رہے ہیں
یو ای کے انفلوینسز انگیج کی ہیں
جو اب پروپگینڈائز کر رہے ہیں
جو اب بقاعدہ کہہ رہے ہیں کہ جناب
حماس کو تباہ ہونا چاہی ہے
حضباللہ کو تباہ ہونا چاہی ہے
مسلم بردرہوڈ کو تباہ ہونا چاہی ہے
فلان کو تباہ ہونا چاہی ہے
ایرالین پارلیمنٹ سپیکر محمد بغیر نے غلیبہ افر نے ایک اور ٹویٹ کی
جہاں پہ انہوں نے کہا کہ ہم نے ان نیسیری گوڈ فیت اینڈ ویل اس مذاکرات میں شامل ہوئے ہیں
لیکن ہمارے جو پچھلے ایکسپینسز ہیں جنگ کے
اس میں ہمیں اگلی سیٹ پہ اتنا اعتبار نہیں تھا
ہمارے جو کالیگز تھے وہ مناب 168 کی ڈیلیگیشن کی شکل میں تھے
یہ 168 وہ بچی ہیں جو شہید ہوئی تھی
اور اس راؤنڈ آف نگوشیشنز میں ہمارے مذاکرات نہیں ہو سکے
امریکہ نے ہمارا منطق اور ہمارے اصول سمجھے ہیں
اب انہوں نے فیصلہ کرنا ہے
کہ وہ کیا کریں گے ہمارا ٹرسٹ چیتنے کے لئے
کیونکہ ایران نگوشیٹنگ
دنیا میں بھی اور جنگ کی دنیا میں بھی
اگریوٹ پارٹی ہے
ایران پہ جنگ مسلط کی گئی
ایران نے جنگ مسلط کی
ایران کے ساتھ مہدے توڑے گئے ہیں
ایران نے کے ساتھ مہدے نہیں توڑے
this is the problem
جب نرندر مودی یہ بات کرتا ہے کہ ہم پاکستان کا پانی بند کریں گے
تو پاکستان کہتا ہے کہ آپ نے
ہمارے ساتھ بیٹھ کے ایک اگریمنٹ کیا تھا
وارٹر کا وہ آپ اوریڈی تھوڑا بہت وائلیٹ کرتے ہیں
تو ہم برداشت کرتے ہیں آپ پانی بند کریں گے
تو ہم آپ کا سانس بند کر دیں گے
یہ ڈی جی آئی سپی آر کے اگزیکٹ
الفاظ تھے آپ جب
نیشن سٹریٹس کو اسطح تھرٹن کرتے ہیں
ایک ایگزیسٹنشل تھرٹ بناتے ہیں تو
پھر آپ کیا توقع کرتے ہیں مثلا کہ
جو سپرائز تھا نرندر موڈی کی شکل
پہ جب انڈیا کے
مزائل گرنے کے بعد پاکستان نے ان کے جہاز گرائے
ان کے ڈرون گرائے اور انڈیا پہ حملہ کیا
یہ بیان المرسوس میں
تو وہ کہتے ہیں یہ کیا کر دیا آپ نے
بندہ کہتا ہے حضور آپ نے یہاں بم مارے
آپ کو کہتا کیا ہوگا اگلے کہیں گے
اوہو کوئی نہیں
اسی طرح ایران میں آپ نے
پچیس سو زیادہ لوگ شہید کر دیا
آپ کو کہتا ہے وہ کیا کریں گے
اور ریالٹی یہ ہے کہ ایکنومک معاملات
اب مزید ایک برا ٹرن لے رہے ہیں
جارج آرول کے نوول 1984 اور کرسچن بیل کی سائی فائی ایکشن مووی
ایکو لیبریم کے درمیان کیا کامن ہے
امیڈیٹلی دیکھتے ہیں تو لگتا ہے کچھ بھی نہیں
لیکن جب گہرائی میں جاتے ہیں تو پتہ لگتا ہے
کہ یہ دونوں ثیمیٹکلی ایک چیز کے بارے میں
وہ ہے دسٹوپین گورمنٹ
اس کو بگ برادر بھی کہتے ہیں
جو بگ برادر جو ہمیشہ دیکھ رہو تھا آپ کو
بگ برادر کا چرچہ تھا بہت آج کل پاکستان کے اندر
لیکن اس طرح کے complicated themes کو سمجھنے کے لیے
ہم نے the club بنایا ہے
کیونکہ پہلے تو صرف ایک book club ہوا کرتا تھا
پشلے ایک ڈیٹھ سال کے لیے
لیکن اب ہم نے اس کو ایک universal club بنا دیا ہے
اس کے اندر کتابیں
popular films, documentaries, articles, published papers
ان ساروں کا مجموعہ بنا کے
ہم thematically month to month
complex ideas کو ایک group setting کے اندر
ایک community کے ساتھ سمجھنے کی کوش کرتے ہیں
تو اگر آپ جوائن کرنا چاہتے ہیں
ایونپوڈکاسٹ.کوم پہ جائیں
اور اپنی میمبرشپ پرچیز کریں
تاکہ ہم جمعے کے جمعے آپ سے ملکات کر سکیں
سی او دیر انشاءاللہ
پاکستان اوبیسلی بار بار اٹیمٹ کرے گا
چائنا اٹیمٹ کرے گا
رشیا اٹیمٹ کرے گا
ایرانین پریزیڈنٹ اور رشیا
کی آپ اس نے بات ہوئی ہے جہاں پہ ایرانین پریزیڈنٹ نے کہا ہے
کہ یار ہمیں گوڈ فیت میں نگوشیٹ کرنا ہے
امریکہ کیا ارکتیں کار رہے ہیں
رشیز نے وہاں پہ یہ بات کی
کہ جناب آپ نگوشیٹس کے راستے کو پرسو کریں
ٹرم سے فاکس نیوز نے یہ پوچھا
کہ جناب جو ایرانین ملٹری ہے
اس کے پاس مجارٹی ایک اپنٹ تو چائنیز ہے
اور چائنہ وہاں پہ مزید مالی بھیج رہا ہے
تو اس نے کہا کہ ہاں شروع میں چائنہ بھیج رہا ہے
لیکن اب نہیں شاید بھیجے گا
اس پہ یہ سوال پوچھا فاکس نیز کے انکر نے کہ جناب وہ تو ان کو اب
ہینڈ ہیلڈ راکٹ ٹو ایر
سوری ہینڈ ہیلڈ
گراؤنڈ ٹو ایر راکٹس دے رہے ہیں
تو اس نے کہا کہ ہاں ہو سکتا ہے
پھر ساتھی یہ بات ہو کہ تم نے پچاس فیسر ٹیرف کی بات
ان کا ہاں چینہ وی پچاس فیسر ٹیرف لگا دے گئے
پیشی دفعہ کیا ہوا تھا جب امریکہ نے ایٹمٹ کیا تھا
امریکن پاپلیشن نے ہی مجبور کہتا ہے گورنن کے ٹیرس ہٹانے کے لیے اور جو کورٹس ہیں وہ تو ٹرمپ کے ٹیرس ہوتے ہیں
ویسی الیگل سمجھتے ہیں تو اس وقت ٹرمپ کو بھی نہیں سمجھ آ رہا کہ یہ ایور چینج ایک سیناریو میں اس نے ایزیکلی کرنا کیا ہے
چائنہ کو کیسے کنٹرول کرنا ہے رشیہ کو کیسے کنٹرول کرنا ہے سٹیٹ آف ہرموز کیسے کھولنا ہے کیوں
کیونکہ جب آپ اپنے آپ کو دنیا کی پولیس مانتے ہو
دنیا کا چودری مانتے ہو
پھر آپ کو دنیا کے مسائل سالف کرنے پڑتے ہیں
اب پورا یورپ ایفیکٹ ہو رہا ہے
جپین ایفیکٹ ہو رہا ہے
ساؤتھ کوریا ایفیکٹ ہو رہا ہے
ساؤتھ اسٹ ایجیا ایفیکٹ ہو رہا ہے
میڈلی اسٹ ایفیکٹ ہو رہا ہے
امریکہ کے پاس کوئی سلوشن نہیں ہے
دنیا کے تھییٹرز آف وار
اس ایک جنگ کی وجہ سے ڈائیورس ہو گئے
there is a theater of war جو Middle East میں
which is the Gulf countries
اور ایران
there is a theater of war جو اسرائیل کے اندر ہے
لبنان کے ساتھ جو وہ کر رہے ہیں
ایک theater of war economic کھل گیا ہے یورپ کے ساتھ
ایک economic theater of war کھل گیا ہے
ساؤتھ اسٹ ایزیا کے ساتھ اور فار اسٹ ایزیا کے ساتھ
یہ صرف ایک جنگ
مسلط کرنے کے بیس ہوئے
وہ بھی امریکہ نے کی
کسی اور نہیں کی
تو لہٰذا اس کا solution اب وہ نکال نہیں پا رہے
اس لیے ان کی پوسٹرنگ عجیب سے عجیب سے عجیب ہو رہی ہے
اور ایسے سینریوز میں پرابلمز بہت ریپڈلی اسکلیٹ کرتی ہیں
پاکستان کیا اتنا کیوں تھٹا اڑایا جا رہا ہے
وہ اس لیے نہیں کہ ان کی سالسی کی ایبیلٹی میں فیلیر تھا
وہ اس لیے کہ انفرشنیٹلی ہم نے اپنی صحافت کو ایک جوک بنا دی
اتنا کرٹیکل سیچویشن ہے پاکستان اتنا بڑا رول پلے کر رہا ہے
رادر دین ڈسکسنگ انفرمیشن وہاں پہ
ڈوئنگ انٹریویوز ویڈ ادھر جنرلیس وہاں پہ
ڈوئنگ انٹریویوز ویڈ فورن
ڈگنٹیز جو وہاں پہ آئے ہوئے تھے
یا گیٹنگ دی انسائٹ سکوپ
ہماری مجورٹی ریپورٹنگ
اس چیز پہ تھی کہ ہم نے کتنا اچھا ایونٹ کیا
یہ کوئی تنک فیسٹ نہیں ہے
یہ کوئی آپ کوک فیسٹ نہیں کرارے
جہاں پہ ایونٹ کی کالٹی پہ تعریف ہونی ہے
اور انفرشنیٹ ریالیٹی ہے کہ لوگ وہاں پہ
کھانوں کی تعریف کر رہے تھے
یہی صحافی جو غریدہ فاروقی صاحبہ
کو پریس کیا گیا تو ان کیا
کہ ہمیں سرکار کی طرف سے
دائریکشن تھا کہ جناب آپ بتائیں
یہاں آنگڑاڈ کی فسیلٹیز کیسی ہیں
تو اس پہ ہم نے تعریف کر دی
غریدہ فاروقی صاحبہ کو چاہیے تھا کہ وہ سرکار
کو اس لمحے میں کہتے کہ حضور یہ وہ ٹائم نہیں ہے کہ آپ یہ باتیں
کریں دنیا آگ میں جمپ کرنے لگی ہے یہ صرف ٹائم میں بات کرنے کا
امن کا اور نگوشیٹ کیسے کیا جائے گا لیکن انفورچنٹلی جہاں
پہ آپ کو سرکاری قسم کی صحافت ملتی ہے اور ایک پٹیکلر برینڈ
اف صحافت ملتی ہے جو اس کا اوپسٹ اینڈ ہے وہ اترا ہی گھٹی ہے
اف نوٹ ورس مجورٹی جو پی ٹی آئی سپورٹی اف صحافی تھے جو آپ
کو انٹرنیٹ پر صحافی ملتے ایون جو اخباروں کے لیے کام کر چکے ہیں
جو ٹی وی چینلل نے کام کر چکے ہیں وہ غریدہ فاروقی صاحبہ کا
آؤٹفٹ ڈسکاس کر رہے تھے مثلا کہ ورلڈ وار تھریز آن دی کارڈز اور
ہماری آپشن کیا ہے غلاب جمن والے صحافی یا آؤٹفٹ والے صحافی
مثلا کہ ہم غیر سنجیدہ قوم تو تھے لیکن ہمارے پڑھے لکھے لوگ
وہ اتنی غیر سنجیتے ہیں
اور ایک عجیب ڈائکوٹمی
بنائی ہوئی ہے گریدہ فاروقی صاحبہ کی تصویر
جوڑی ہوئے ایک ایرانین صحافی کے ساتھ
اور کہا جا رہا ہے کہ دیکھیں ان کا آؤٹفٹ کتنا غلط ہے
ان کا آؤٹفٹ کتنا اچھا ہے
آپ کون ہیں یہ فیصلہ کرنے والے
ہو آر یو دو ڈیسائیڈ
آپ اپنے ملک میں
شریعت کا نظام نافذ نہیں کر سکے
اور پوری شریعت آپ نے گریدہ فاروقی
بتار دینی ہے
آپ کی ریاست جب مسلمان شہید ہو رہے ہیں دنیا بھر میں کچھ بھی نہیں کر رہی
آپ کو غریدہ فروکی کی ریسنگ سے پرولم ہو رہی ہے کیوں
کیونکہ یہ ایک مقصود پولیٹیکل سوچ کے تحت ہے
یہ فلسفہ نہیں ہے
وہ سوچ یہ ہے کہ ہمارا کتہ ٹومی اگلے ہے کتہ کتہ
اور یہی چیز ہماری پاکستان کی پولٹیکس کو اور ہماری معاشرت کو تباہ کر رہی ہے
بھائی اگر آپ کو لگتا ہے کہ اصولی طور پر دنیا سیکلر ہونی چاہیے
یا اصولی طور پر دنیا شریع ہونی چاہیے
تو یہ آپ کا فلسفہ ہے
اس کے لئے آپ جی تجھے حد کرتے ہیں
اس میں انڈیویجولز نہیں میٹر کرتے ہیں
انڈیویجول کرتیسزمز نہیں میٹر کرتی
آپ پیٹنز دیکھتے ہیں
ریالٹی یہ ہے
کہ پاکستان ایک ویسل سٹیٹ رہا ہے
جو انٹرمیڈیٹری ہوتا ہے
مختلف نیشن سٹیٹس کا
یہ ہمارا سگنیچر رہا ہے
فور سیونٹی پلاس ہیئرز
ہم نے اپنی منفیکچنگ پر
ڈیویلپنٹ نہیں کی ہم نے اپنی صحافت پر
ڈیویلپنٹ نہیں کی ہم نے اپنی ایڈیوکیشن
پر ڈیویلپنٹ نہیں کی ہم نے نیشنل ایڈینٹی پر
ڈیویلپنٹ نہیں کی تو اس سب پر کلمنیشن
یہ ہے کہ we are a confused nation
اس لیے آپ کو ہر قسم کا لباس
ملے گا جو کلیم کرے گا کہ ہم اسلام میں
کہیں یا نون اسلام میں کہیں
تو آپ
ایک پرنسپل کے لیے فائٹ کرتے ہیں
not particular political point scoring pro PTI
ہم صحافی کی انٹیلیکچول ابلیٹی کو ڈائسیکٹ نہیں کرتے
ہم اس کے لباس اس کی پولٹیکل لیننگز اس کی تنخواہ اس کو ڈائسیکٹ کرتے
اور جو وہ کاروائی ڈال رہا ہوتا ہے
برین واشنگ کے نام پہ وہ اگنور ہو جاتی ہے
like for example
اگر آپ کوئی کہتا ہے کہ آپ شباز گل کو نہ سنیں
کیونکہ شباز گل یو تھی ہے
what does that mean
کیا اس کا ہر تجزیہ غلط ہے
not really
ازاد سعید صاحب اتنے تجزیہ دیتے ہیں جو غلط ثابت ہوتے ہیں
آسمان شرازی صاحب نے
ٹویٹس کی
ٹویٹس مجود ہیں
جہاں پہ وہ بتا رہی ہیں کہ بگ نیوز کمیں گے
سون result نکلن لگا ہے لیکن تھوڑی دیوہ بجھلا ہے
talks fail کر گی
ایک guesstimation چل رہی ہوتی ہے
ان مذاکرات کا یہ result نکلے گا
اور reality یہ ہے پاکستانی جنرلیزم کو access نہیں دیا گیا
کیوں پاکستانی جنرلیزم
ٹوٹل کھڑی ہوتی ہے establishment news پہ
نونلی نے کچھ بتا دیا
پی ٹی آئی نے کچھ بتا دیا
اور یہ وہ report کر دیتے ہیں
یہ لوگ کبھی field reporter سے اوپر جائی نہیں سکے
اور پھر یہ اتنے بڑے celebrities بن گئے
خود اپنی ذاتوں میں
کہ ان کا فیلڈ رپورٹر والا کام بھی رہ گیا
پھر یہ کمروں میں بیٹھ کے
نیوز رپورٹنگ کرتے ہیں
انویسٹیکیٹو جنرلزم تو ہمارے ملک میں ہے نہیں
آپ کے ملک میں
کتنی کو آپ کو ڈاکیمنٹریز مل جاتی ہیں
بنیوں جو کسور
چائلڈ سیکس رنگ تھا اس کے اوپر
آپ کو کتنی مل گیوں
پاکستان کے اندر ٹیررس سیلز
کیسے آپریٹ کرتے ہیں
آپ کو کتنی مل گیوں
کہ پاکست پنجاب میں ڈرگ ٹریڈ کہاں سے ہوتا ہے
آپ کو
ٹیمبر مافیاں پہ کتنی مل گی ہوں
آپ کو کتنی ڈاکیمنٹریز مل گی ہوں
on white collar crimes کچھ بھی نہیں
شازوں ناظر کو youtube attempt کر لے
بہتر ہم نے تین سال میں رخیال ہے
پندرہ بیس ویڈیوز بنائی ہیں
white collar crime پہ جتنی اس میں محنت لگتی ہے
آپ کا سامنے
ہم نے پانچھے ویڈیوز بنائی ہیں
large scale private corporation
tax evasion کے اوپر
تو بڑی محنت لگتی ہے
تو یہ لوگ اس چیز کے عادی نہیں ہیں
تو اس لیے پھر ان لوگ کو عادت ہے کہ
ہمیں بس میں بٹھاؤ
بس سے ہمیں کنونشن سینٹر لے کے جاؤ
کنونشن سینٹر میں بتا دو کیا بات کرنی ہے
اور غریتہ فاروقی صاحبہ نے ایک ٹویٹ میں کہا
کہ جناب جو
ہم نے بات کی تھی تاریف کی
انتظامات کی
اس کے علاوہ سا دن ہم تجزیہ بھی کرتا رہے
تو پھر ہم نے ان کا لائف سٹریم دیکھی
ان کا پروگرام دیکھا
وہ تجزیہ نہیں کر رہے تھے
وہ بھی ریپورٹنگ ہی ہو رہی تھی
مثلا کہ جو اکثر آپ دیکھتے ہیں
سٹوڈیو سے کہتے ہیں
ہاں جی آپ گراؤنڈ پر ہم بتائیں کیا ہے
تو قریدہ فروکی صاحب ووگ کر رہی تھی
اور کیونکہ انٹرنیشنل جنرلس ساتھ تھے
انٹرنیشنل آئی سی
تو ہر کسی نے اپنے ٹاپ اینکرز
موقعے کے اوپر بھیجے
اور ہم نے جو ہماری صحافت کا لیول ہے
وہ تب بھی دیکھا تھا جب مہارنگ بلوچ سے سوال جواب ہو رہے تھے
ہم نے وہ بھی دیکھا تھا
دو مختلف خواتین ہی سوال کرنے گئی تھی
تو انفارسنیٹ یہ ایک ریالیٹی ہے
لیکن ہمارے پاس جو آپشنز ہیں وہ اتنی ہی بری ہیں
گلاب جامن یا کپڑے
یہ ہمارے پاس آپشنز ہیں
کھنٹی
کئی دفعہ ہم لوگ بھی انٹرنیشنل انیلسز لینے کے لیے
لوکل نائسز لینے کے لیے باہر کی خبریں دیکھ رہے ہوتے ہیں
کیونکہ یہاں پہ جو ڈیبیٹ ہو رہی ہوتی ہے وہ ڈیبیٹ نہیں ہے
وہ ڈیبیٹ آن آئیڈیز ڈیبیٹ آن پرسنیلٹیز ہوتی ہے
میرن سٹیم ٹی وی چانس بھی دیکھیں
وہ فارمولا ہاتھ جگہ چلتا ہے
اور یہ کس ٹائم ہو رہا ہے
ورڈ وار تھری کے برکل آپ سمجھیں
سٹارٹنگ پر ہو رہا ہے
it is almost absurd
again
ہماری جو میڈیا کلاس ہے
جو انٹیلیجنسیا کلاس ہے
جو ہماری سیول سوسائٹی تھی
اس کو تباہ کر کے ایسی چیز بنا دیا گیا ہے
کہ یہ ایلیٹس ہیں آئیوری ٹاورز کے اندر بیٹھے ہیں
ان کو نہیں فکر پڑتا
تیل مہنگا ہو سستا ہو
گیس بہنگی ہو سستی ہو
کیونکہ ان کی تنخواہیں ان کے پرکس ان کے پیسے اتنے زیادہ ہوتے ہیں
آپ
آپ نے اکثر یہ بات سنی ہوگی
کہ امیر لوگ یہ بات کرتے ہیں
یا لوگ زیادہ محنت کیوں نہیں کرتے
گرمی ہے
بھوک ہے
بجلی کا بل نہیں دیا جا رہا
لوگوں کے گھر جن کی ایوریس تنخواہ
35-40 زار پر ہے
اگر بجلی کا بل آ جائے گا
وہ کیا کریں گے
یہ باتیں تب ہوں
اگر صحافی لوگوں کی
ویل ریپیزنٹ کریں
اگر پارلیمنٹ لوگوں کی
ایسا نہیں ہے
ہمارے ہاں
پولٹیشنز اور صحافی
سیم سوسائٹیوں میں رہتے ہیں
یعنی کہ لاہور کی پوش علاقہ کیا ہوگا
مولٹان کینٹ
تو صحافی پولٹیشن دونوں وہاں رہیں گے
جب آپ ان پوش علاقوں میں رہتے ہیں
جہاں ہر چیز صاف ہوتی ہے
درہ خوبصورت ہوتے ہیں
پرندے چیکرے ہوتے ہیں
پارک میں آپ واکس کر رہے ہوتے ہیں
ہر کوئی اپنے چھوٹے ڈاگیز کے ساتھ واک کر رہا ہوتا ہے
تو آپ کہتے ہیں سب ٹھیک ہے
دیکھیں سب اچھا ہے
سب چلے گا
اگر ہم پی ٹی آئی کی بھی بگ فور یا بگ فائیو دیکھیں جس میں عمران عیاز خان صاحب ہیں شباز گل صاحب ہیں آپ کے وجات خان صاحب ہیں آپ کے مہت پیزادہ صاحب ہیں صاحب شاکر صاحب ہیں یہ غریب لوگ نہیں ہیں یہ بھی اسی الیٹ ون پرسن کو بلانگ کرتے ہیں ٹھیک ہے کچھ لوگ ایک میڈل کلاس فیملی سے اٹھ کے ہیں محنت سے کر کے ہیں بہت تیار بہت رچ پیپل اور آج ان کی محبت عوام اسی وجہ سے ہے
کیونکہ وہ عوام کھڑی گئی ہے
with a political party
fast forward 5 years from now
یا rewind 5 years back
very different attitude
مثلا کہ میں سمجھتا ہوں کہ
جب opposition میں political جماعتیں ہوتی ہیں
اور ان کے صحافی ہوتے ہیں
تب ان کی journalism اور democracy کا belief پیک پہ ہوتا ہے
یعنی کہ
بہت کم صحافی ہیں
جیسے اصلی طور
جو ہر دور میں equally hated ہیں
یہ اس بندے کو اعزاز ہے
میڈل ہے
کہ بھائی جو دور آیا ہے
گورنمنٹ نے اصلی طور سے نفرت کی
مطیع اللہ جان سے نفرت کی ہے
یہ بیج آف آنڈر ہے
اگر آپ ان کی لائف ٹائل دیکھ لینا
تو نظر آتا ہے کہ انہوں نے صحافت کی ہے
مثلا کہ میں اصلی تور کو ملا ہوں
زیادی طور پر
جس گاڑی میں وہ تشریف لائے تھے
میں گاڑی نہیں بتا ہوں گا کون سچے
لیکن آپ سمجھ لیں گے وہ گاڑی کو
دس گیارہ بارہ لاکھ والی ہے
ٹھیک ہے پرانی گاڑی ہے
اور شہبی سے انہیں کپڑے ہیں
پتلا دبلہ سمارٹ آدمی
با کپڑے پتا چلتا ہے کہ اتنے مہنگے نہیں ہیں شاہبی سے ہیں
اور نارمو صاحب
ٹھینڈا میٹر صاحب بندہ ہے
مطیلہ جان صاحب کو دیکھ لیں
لین کو پیسے دے دولر دے ترقی دے
ہم اس سے اگنس نہیں ہیں لیکن
آگو پتا چلتا ہے کہ یہ لوگ سیکرفائس کرتے ہوئے آ رہے ہیں
تو ریالیٹی یہ ہے کہ
اتنے کرٹیکل مومنٹ پہ جب پاکستان میں
اتنی بڑی چیز ہو رہی تھی
تو ہم نے ہمارے صحافیوں کو ایکسس نہیں دیا
تاکہ وہ دنیا کو بتا سکیں گے
ہم بھی کوئی پاور ہیں
اور ہمارے صحافیوں نے یہ ڈیمانڈ بھی نہیں کی
انہوں نے یہ خواہش بھی نہیں لگتا ہے
کہ ہمیں بھی بتایا اندر کیا اور ہمیں بھی اندر گھسائیں
مثلا کہ اتنے انٹرنیشنل جنرلسٹ آئے ہوئے تھے
میری ازمشن یہ تھی
کہ ہر پرائم ٹائم ٹی وی پہ
کوئی نہ کوئی گورا کورسپانڈن
یا کسی ایراب کورسپونڈنٹ
یا کسی ایجن کورسپونڈنٹ
کے ساتھ شو کیا جائے گا
میری یہ ازمشن تھی
پوچھا جائے گا آپ کیا سوچتے ہیں
آپ کا ملک کیا سوچتے ہیں
یہ باتیں ہوں گی
نہیں ہوا
وہاں پہ جو انٹرنیشنل صحافی تھے
وہ لور لور پھر کے
اینڈ میں نے کہا
کچھ مل نہیں رہا
تو چلو سائیڈ لیفت
رائٹ لیفت ہو جاؤ
تو آپ کے پاس ایک میجر اوپرٹیونٹی تھی
between Indian پاکستان
انڈیا ہی چول ہے
ہمیں unfortunately یہ ایک safety
لیٹ ہے ہمارا یہ بڑا
انڈیا اتنا بڑا چول ہے
صحافت کے محملے میں کہ ہماری چولیں
چولیں نہیں لگتی یہ reality ہے
لیکن ہم بھی
شوڑ بھی better ہمیں اس چیز سے
اوپر نکلنا ہے
اب ٹرمپ کو
بار بار ایک سوال کیا جا رہا ہے
mid term elections کے point of view سے
اور اب آپ کو سمجھ جائے گا
یہ مذاکرات کام کیوں نہیں کرنے تھے
mid term elections کے اندر
ٹرمپ کی ہونی ہے کتے والی
بظاہر یہ لگ رہے
ٹرمپ کو major wins
چاہیے ہیں election جیتے جاتے ہیں
from a position of power
اگر ٹرمپ deal negotiate کر دیں
mid term سے پہلے تو پوری
democratic party یہ ہار گیا
ہار گیا ٹرمپ
ٹرمپ کی پھٹ گی
ٹرمپ کچھ نہیں کال سکا
یہ سارے بیانیے چلائے جائیں گے
یہ negotiations تو کامیاب
ہو نہیں سکتی تھی کیوں
کیونکہ ان طاقتور ملک
اور ان کے امیر لیڈروں کو یہ نہیں فرق پڑتا
کہ کتنے آپ نے براؤن لوگ
تو اس میں اس نے کہا تھا کہ ایران کی فوج امریکہ کی فوج سے نہیں جیتی ہے
امریکن گورنمنٹ نے پولٹیکل ویل ہار دی اپنے پیپل کی
اس کی وجہ سے ان کو نگوشیئیڈ کرنا پڑا ہے
ورنہ امریکہ کی فوج کے پاس ایسی چیزیں ہیں جو نسٹوں نابود کر دے ایران کو
اور اس کی بات یہ سچ ہے
ملٹری پاور میں امریکہ بہت اوپر ہے ایران سے
لیکن جنگیں صرف جہازوں سے نہیں لڑی جاتی
ایکچل پولٹیکل ویل سے لڑی جاتی ہے
دنیا حیران ہو گی تھی کہ ایران کے لوگ جو ڈیوائیڈ تھے ایسے ایک مٹھ ہو گئے
مثلا رضا پیلوی پشاپ کی جھاکی طرح اوپر گیا پھر نیچے آگیا اقدام سے
ختم ہو گیا
اس نے کوئی سو دو سو بندوں کا پروٹیسٹ
انگلینڈ میں کرانے کوشکیہ نکام ہو گیا
لیکن امریکہ کے اندر
ایک مٹھ نہیں ہو سکے لوگ کیوں کیونکہ ایران
تھریٹ ہی نہیں ہے ان کے لیے
الٹا کیا ہوا کہ امریکہ کے لوگ ایک مٹھ ہو گئے
رائٹ ونگ یا لیفٹ ونگ یا سینٹر کے کہیں بھی لوگ
اسرائیل کے خلاف
کہ جناب کیا کر رہے ہیں اب اسرائیل کے جو
فیکٹ سامنے آ رہے ہیں کہ ان کی
ملٹری موبلائزیشن راکٹ دیفنس سسٹم
تو ہر چیز کا جو خرچہ ملٹریلی آئے
وہ گیارہ ارب ڈالر ہے
یہ پیسے کون دے گا امریکن ٹیکس پر
کو پتا ہے وہ دیں گے کیونکہ امریکن
ملٹری امریکن سٹیٹ سبسیڈائز
کرتا ہے ہر چیز اسرائیل کے اندر
انکلوڈنگ دے ملٹری ایسٹس
تو دی امریکن پیپل
ڈونٹ ہیوٹھ ایران
ہائیور ٹرامپ کو ضرورت ہے
کہ ایران میں ایک definitive victory ہو
تاکہ وہ mid term elections میں جا سکے
کہ اس کی بہت multiple ہی تو چکی ہے
so talks نہیں کام کی اور آگے بھی
ہمارا تجزیہ کے نہیں کوئی آپ کو
ceasefire type situation
یا کوئی ایسی situation جہاں پہ
international financial markets
stable ہوتی ہوئی نظر ہیں
یا ایران کی situation stable ہوتی ہوئی نظر ہیں
اب اس ساری صورتحال کے اندر پاکستان نے
یہ اب again
جی جی آئیس پر آگرس پر statement نہیں آیا
آج کے دن میں آ جانا چاہیے
پاکستان نے troops move کر دی ہیں
سعودہ ریبیا کے اندر
اسی پٹیکلر بیس میں جو ایران کے بالکل سامنے ہے
جہاں پہ اٹیکس ہوتے رہے ہیں
وہاں پہ غالباً انہوں نے جی ایف سیونٹین
یا اپنے جو جہاز ہیں رڑا کا
جی ایف سیونٹین ہیں
جہاز بھی موو کر دی ہیں
ہو سکتا ہے کہ اس نگوشیشن کے اندر
ایک سائیڈ پارٹی
کئی باتیں ہو رہی ہوتی ہیں
کئی پوائنٹس ہوتے ہیں تو سائیڈ پہ بھی میٹنگز ہو رہی ہوتی ہیں
اس میں شاید یہ پوائنٹ نکلاؤ
کہ ایران اگر جنگ اسکلیٹ ہوتی ہے تو
سعودی ریبیہ کو ڈیک نہیں کرے گا
کیونکہ یو ای نہیں چھوڑتا وہ
یہ آپ لکھ لیں کہ اگر جنگ اسکلیٹ ہوتی ہے
کسی قسم کی پرابلم
کریٹ کی جاتی ہے ایران کی تو دنیا میں
کچھ ہو نہ ہو وہ یو ای کو نہیں چھوڑے گا
کیونکہ جو یو ای نے کردار دا
کیا ہے پچھلے
پندرہ بیس سال
ساری مسلم ریاستے ان کو نہیں پسند کرتی
ساری
سعودی ریبیا اور یوئی ایئی
نے آپس میں نا ابھی آمنے
سامنے ہو گئے تھے پچھلے ڈیڑھ دو سال میں
ایک ایفریکن نیشن سٹیٹ کی ایشو پہ
تو اس پہ سعودی ریبیا نے
یوئی کو آنکھت گھائی دی یوئی دوم دبا کے
وہاں سے بھاگا تھا
تو یوئی کی اصل میں اوقات کو حصیت کوئی نہیں ہے
چلو طاقتور ملک ان کو
adjust کر لیتے ہیں تو وہ adjust ہوئے تھے
militarily تیار
اور سعودہ ریبیہ نے جو آنکھیں دکھائی تھی
وہ پاکستان کی فوج کی سر پہ دکھائی تھی
یہ reality ہے
صاف آپ کو سمجھ آتا ہے کہ
پاکستان سعودہ ریبیہ کا جو
military political nexus ہے وہ بہت
close ہے وہاں پہ ہماری فوج
ابھی کی نہیں کہیں دیر کی سرف کار رہی
مثلا کہ ہمارے
missions وہاں پہ جا رہے ہیں since the 60s
and 70s there's nothing new
اب وہ بڑے پیمانے پہ ہو گیا
تو انفورچنیٹلی
سارے کارڈز اس وقت
یا ایران کے پاس ہیں
یا ٹرمپ کے پاس ہیں
پاکستان ٹرائیڈ ایٹس بیسٹ
سعود ارابیہ ٹرائیڈ ایٹس بیسٹ
چائنہ نے بھی ٹرائے کیا رشیا نے بھی ٹرائے کیا
رشیا کو تو جو ایکنومک فائدہ ہوئے
شٹیٹ اف ہرموز کا
نہ تو سے انہوں نے تیل مہنگا بیچنا شروع کر دیا
بلکہ ان پر لگائے ویٹ ٹیروس بھی اٹھا جی تھے
لیکن اب امریکہ وہ ٹیروس مزید لفٹ نہیں کر رہا
کیوں وہ ریشن تیل کو بھی چوک کرنا چاہتا ہے
وہ ایران کے بلوکیڈ کو بلوکیڈ کے جواب دینا چاہتا ہے
تاکہ وہ دنیا کو مجبور کرے کہ ایران سکھاؤ کے میری باتیں مانیں
ٹرمپ بیسیلی بولی ٹائپ منٹیلٹی کا آدمی ہے
اس کا صرف کام یہ کہ لوگوں پر پریشر ڈالنا بولی کرنا
تاکہ وہ اس کی بات مان جائے
اور یہ چیز کام کرتی رہی ہے کیوں
کیونکہ وہ اس بغیرتی کے لیول پر چلا گیا ہے
کہ کھلے آم
اس کے بارے میں فیکٹ سامنے آگئے ہیں
کہ وہ چھوٹی بچوں سے زیادتی کہتا تھا
اب تو اس کی بیگم نے بھی آکے
پبلکلی کہہ دے کہ جناب میں وکٹم نہیں ہوں
ایپسٹین کی بندہ پوچھتا ہے بہن تجھے پوچھا کس نے ہے
پوری امریکن نیو سائیکل
گلوبل نیو سائیکل کوئی تعلق ہی نہیں ہے
ٹھیک ہے کہ ملانیا کیا سوچتی
اپسٹین ملانے کے بارے میں کیسے
ملانیا اور اپسٹین کا مراسم تصویروں کو تیار پرانا ثابت ہوگئے
پری ٹرمپ بھی
ٹھیک
اب واللہ ہی ہمیں نہیں پتا کیا کہتے ہیں
کہ ٹرمپ کے پاس اپسٹین نے اس کو بھیجتا ہے
کیا ہوا تھا لیکن they knew each other
it's as simple as that
in fact most American socialites said
کہ نیو یورک social scene میں in the 90s
and 80s everyone knew
who اپسٹین was
everyone was friends with him
it's as simple as that
کہیں آپ کے گرد و نوام میں لوگ بھیڑیے بیٹھے ہوتے ہیں
لوگوں سے ملتے ہیں اٹھتے بیٹھتے ہیں ہر چیز کتے ہیں نہیں پا چلتا
اسی سارے کے دوران جو فلوٹیلا تھی جنہوں نے جا کے پہلے کوشش کی تھی
غزہ کے آگے پیچھے جو اسرائیل نے بلوکیڈ لگایا ہے
جو چالیس کشتیاں گئی تھی پشلے اکتوبر میں وہ اب دوبارہ جا رہی ہیں
یعنی کہ غزہ کے لوگوں کی پلائٹ وہی پہ کھڑی ہے
اور آپ یاد کریں کہ پاکستان کی ریاست نے بھی کریکٹون کیا تھا یہاں پہ
اور انٹرنیشنلی بھی بتایا گیا تھا کہ جناب غازہ کی پیس ڈیل ہو گی ہے
ریاست نے کہا تھا پیس ڈیل ہو گیا پاکستان کی آباد کیوں کہہ رہے ہیں
روز وہاں پہ قتلیں عام ہو رہے ہیں
وہاں پہ جینوسائیڈ کا لیول جس پہ چلا گیا ہے وہ اب شاید ارورسیبل ہے
میں نہیں کہہ رہاں ڈبلیو ایچو کہہ رہا ہے جو وہاں پہ ہیلتھ امپیکٹس آ گیا
اب اللہ کرے
یہ کہتے ہیں کہ
جو جنگ ہے
وہ کسی کنکلوجن کی طرف پہنچے
دنیا میں جو انرجی کا کرائسس بن رہا ہے
جو نائٹروجن بیسٹ فرٹلائزر کرائسس بن رہا ہے
یہ ابیٹو
اللہ کرے ایران کی جو سورینٹی ہے وہ تھریٹن نہ کی جائے
اس کو از این نیشن سٹیٹ فنکشن کرنے دیا جائے
لیکن کیونکہ امریکن میڈ ٹرمز آ رہے ہیں
کیونکہ اسرائیل کا ایگزسٹینشل کرائسس
ایسپسٹی نیٹین یاوکلی فور گریٹر اسرائیل
کیونکہ یو ای ای کو شوٹ کرتا ہے
کہ ایران کبھی ڈیولپ نہ کرے
ایس اپورٹ سٹی
ایس ای نیشن سٹیٹ
وہنے پاکستان ساتھ کیا یو ای ای نے
تو سیچویشن اچھی نہیں لگ دی
باقی میری درخواست ہوگی پاکستان کی ریاست سے
فیل مارشل آسیم نیش شباز شریف
ہمارے جتنے طاقتور لوگ ہیں اس ملک میں
کہ پلیز سر
ہمارے ملک میں صحافت ہونے دیں
ہمارے ملک میں
انٹیلیکچول تھوٹ کو پروانہ دیں
لوگوں میں ایک بحث کی
ایک اپیٹائٹ کریئٹ ہونے دیں
اچھے لوگوں کو ایکسز دیں
جنرلزم کی انڈسٹری میں بڑے اچھے
قابل لوگ ہیں
ان کو ایکسز دیں
let them ask questions
let them ask tough questions
آپ capable ہیں ان کے جواب دینے کے لیے
nation wants to know
یہ ارناب کی میند کل نہیں اترار تھا
میں آپ کو درقی کر بتا رہا ہوں
پوری عوام جو ڈی ویسی دیکھنے کے لئے
اسلامباد میں کیا ہو رہا ہے
ان کو وہاں سے کیا دیکھنے کو ملا
اول تو اتا تار صاحب
کلیریفکیشن دینی چاہیے
دہ فارقی صاحب نے ان کو بس کنڈر تھو کر دیا
پلیز
ہم اتنے برے نہیں ہیں
ہم اتنے گھٹیا نہیں ہیں
کہ آپ اس لیول کا ہمیں بے فکوف سمجھیں
یا ہم سے نفرت کریں
یہ میری اپیل ہے
ایز مسلمان
ایس سٹیزن آف پاکستان
حالانکہ مجھے پتا ہے کہ ہماری حیثیت اوقات نہیں ہے
آپ لوگ ساتھ برابری کرنے کے لئے
یہ جو بڑے بڑے چینلوں میں بیٹھے ہوتے ہیں
یہ جو بڑے بڑے دفتروں میں بیٹھے ہوتے ہیں
لیکن بندہ بھیگ تو مانگ سکتا ہے
ویسے بھی ہمیں بتایا گیا ہے کہ
یہ دشمن نے نہیں بتایا تھا
شباشی صاحب نے بتایا تھا
تو میں ایس یہ پاکستانی آپ سے بھیگ مانتا ہوں
خدا کے واسطے
ہمارے ملک میں گفتگو کا میہار بہتر کروائیں
لوگوں کا انٹیلیکچول کیلبر بہتر کروائیں
نہیں تو بھوک ننگ تو تھی
لیکن جن ایشیوز پہ ہمیں دوسرے کو مرنے مارنے کو تیار ہیں
وہ بنتا نہیں ہے
ہمیشہ کی طرح آپ کا سننے کا شکریہ